一操作说明按w是向前，按s是向后，按a是向左，呃按d是按右
按空格是跳，然后鼠标可以控制我们的视角看周围，然后左键是用打用刀砍，按右键是发魔法
这个魔法可以自动追踪
二小孩为何会自主学习？
如果我们遇到怪物不念单词的话会打得很慢，如果念出单词的话就能实现暴击伤害
Lemon lemon
这样子就使孩子会想念单词
现在给大家表演一个打boss，如果不破防他会打的很慢
它有个防护罩，就是这外面的这些蓝色的东西，现在我准备破它房了，Pardon
呐，防护罩变成红色了，就说明它破防了
破防了就非常好打
这样子我们就不得不学英语
左下角如果我不念单词的话，它会增加一个数字过来，看看我今天学了多少
总共学习
已学二百二十五。总词数四千三百二十六，现在只学了第一关的单词
三越玩越想学，如果我们有钱了，可以去第二关第三关
包括包括这难的第六关进第二关花了我一万块钱
这是一个声音。这里面的怪怪物掉的钱钱都很多，长的经验值也很快
Approximately. A pricing motley
这样的。这就是三四年级的单词了，Face catch catch
然后按f就可以和商人交易，把这个名片给卖掉
这个卖掉，这些卖没用的东西都可以卖掉
然后这里其实是有个操作按钮的
点击这个问号就可以展开
都是英文的，要认识才才行，其实我刚才说的所有东西这这里都有